Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Lunacy Saint Rhodes.
Now this is a demo to an ongoingly developed game. It's a horror game.
So..
If you need any more than that, you don't know what this game is all about, but this game looked fantastic from what I saw.
And uh..
judging by what I see now,
I'm inclined to agree with it
Ahh.
Spoooky
Anybody in there?!
Oh crows, alright then..
So I don't know what to doooo..?
Oh okay, I thought..I thought I saw a shadow moving across the wall but I was wrong...
I don't know what to dooo, and I don't know what this game wants from me
so I'm just gonna try to do it as best as I can..
Do I have a FLASHLIGHT? Or do I just need to-
*thunder roars*
Guess I have my answer!
Thank you for that.
Now let me clear the poop out of my pants and carry on with my adventure!
Alright.
The fuuuck..
*mumbles*
Hello..
Ah!
Lovely! Is this the lunacy of which I was spoken about?
Hi...
Always my favorite thing.
Oooh, I should have read this, huh?
Oh!
Flasher-light!
Oh boy... "Hey, Sweetie, just to let you know
I won't be coming home till midnight. If you come home earlier,
please leave the lights on and go to sleep as soon as you can."
Why would I need to leave the lights on?! That's a waste of power Mama.
Should have come for this... sooner... Mom.
Ugh... I hate this house Mom!
It's full of demons..
Woah - k every door is also looooocked.
Ah, that's what I did I opened tha... Fuck.
I got scared by a banister.
I got scared by a goddamn railing.
Ugh. That's what I got scared -
*thunder* Ah okay...
Enough of that, you rumbly wumbly bumbly bitch.
Oooh, finally! An open door! Who'd of thunked it in this house?
In my house...?!
Okay.
So far, so goo
So far, so I don't know what to dooo--
*doorbell ringing*
HI.
*doorbell still ringing*
MOM!
*doorbell continues to ring* MOOOOOOM!
MOOOM. Who's home? Is that you, Mom? I can't figure out how to turn on the liiiiggghttts...
*thunder* MOM.
Oh boy. Yeah, I'm just gonna go and BRACE FOR IMMPAACT...
*scary DUNNNN sound*
Hi. Hello. How can I help you?! I ALREADY BOUGHT MY SHARE OF GIRL SCOUT COOKIES!
*slight thunder*
Alright. You just have fun wandering around in my yard!
Which seems to be the backyard for some reason 'cause it's fenced in.
I don't understand that but just -  I'm just gonna accept it.
ME NO LIKEY THIS.
Me no like - HEEYY! OH!
You're open.
Hey railing, do you have any opinions about this? Oh, okay, a bunch of dicketry happening over here, you say?!
*wood breaking noise *
*gasp* Fuck you.
Who the hell...
do you think you are.
Ooh, hello. Ah.
"January 7th, 1905.
I found a door hidden behind the cabinet in a room. After searching the whole damn place,
I found the key on the top shelf in one of the tea cups. I hesitated going inside for a while.
I thought she might be there. I finally entered and I saw -
*fake scream* AAH!!!
... presence... I locked the door hid the key behind the... DERTH"
K, very helpful. Thank you. Just may be creeped out. You didn't actually do anything for me
*elongated wind/ghost breathing*
Ok. Alright. How 'bout that then.
I can do that, too. I just don't feel like participating in your adventure.
Ah. Yes. Ooh. Very dark and shadowy.
I don't know what that says, but that's some sort of writing. That's some sort of Slendermaaaan.
So... that's the thing that you were talking about. I - I don't know how to...
... unlock it 'cause you said something about a key, and I don't know where that is.
The key behind the... *random noises*
The key behind the... what..
The key behind the... *more random jumbled noises*
The key's got to be behind something.
Oh. Hello. Ah. Ha ha. Ah.
Convenian-tay. Thank you for the guiding hand. I'll take this key, I - I suppose.
I'll unlock this, I suppose.
Can I do that? Oh not that one? Okay. Wait. What did I unlock then?
Or what am I gonna unlock? Guess I'll read the note again...
"a door hidden behind the cabinet in a room" Okay.
So there's a cabinet here. Ah the decorum in this place is just to die - Oh hello.
Mother's bedroom key...
Ooh.
Audacious. Where's Mother's bed-
*thunder*
If it's not up here, where could it be? Is it this one over hereuhh?
Ooh yay.
Aaaah.
Saucy... Hello.
*thunder*
Oof, all right, hope my mother doesn't mind me intruding in her  room
Still just as gloomy in here as it is anywhere else..OK so there's..is there something behind this cabinet? Oh hello
Okay, she is gone. I can't believe she's gone. I searched the whole house many times and still nothing the stupid business trip-
I should have stayed with her these few days before our wedding
I just don't understand where she could be, and why the wedding dress? Why is it the only thing missing
What was she trying to do?
I don't know ruin your wedding?? Maybe..
ooh hello, oh ah
OK, behind the flower,, pot..?
So there's something behind the flowerpot. Or it's saying don't touch it.
OOOOOOH
OOOooh!
I'm so strong.
Oh boy, OHHH, I don't like that. Hi-AH THAT MAKES MY BLOOD BOIL
OOOH, I DON'T LIKE YOU. Hi? Okay? Alright? Oh boy. Hey, oh fuuck you
*man groaning and scary DUUNNN sound*
Okay, fine. You know I'm okay with that oh, hiiiii
oHHH HIII
*scared noises*
*more scared, slightly bear-like noises*
What is that? Oh, that's not good.. That's not good
*mumbling*
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAEYYYYYYY...
*slow inhale*
*slow exhale*
Oh hi.. I hate everything about this
*sigh* But I'm a brave boy. Ima face you
come at me bro. Come at me bro COME AT ME BRO-COME AT ME BRUH..Yeah, you-EAAAYYY
better run
You stay over there. Are you facing me now? Huh?
*squeaky* is that what you think what you think you were doing??
is that what you think you're gonna be doing? I will have you know that I am a badass
*evil groaning noises*
I am gonna stab you in your groaning throat
I will stab you in your eyes, and then you will die
Eat a dick and then go..
fall in a hole
Well, I'm gonna follow the groaning then..I'll follow the groaning out into the hallway wherever that may lead
me
oh *unintelligible mutters*
*sudden noise*
*gasp*
ffucking stop..
Stop. Stop it. Stop. *weird posh accent* I don't want it. I don't want any of it. I don't want it
Who is banging..was it out here, or was it somewhere else?
*clock chiming*
What's with the BONGING!? *phone rings* Oh, okay? Sure yeah, let's go with this one. Hello?
Hellhole Apartments.
Hello
*static and phone beeping*
What'd you say don't do what, don't hum- don't hump me?
*doorbell*
Moooom?
There's the-oh hi, okay. What the- well there's a problem with your leg there
*loud noises and whispers* BODY BOOOOO
*more whispering and scary background music*
OOOOOHHH
OH that's not good.
*doorbell repeatedly ringing*
OH BOY OK LETS OPEN IT UP
LETS OPEN HER UP
YEEEEE
UHHHH fine fine fine fine okay, uh what do I do what do I do what do I do?
YEeEeEEeE
OK
OK, all right, I guess that's okay. I guess it's all better now up here. Can I hide in this hole--OH. Hi
Hello, I see you there. Why are you there?
*door creaking open*
*gasp*
hhhhiii
oh hi
Oh yeah, sure, okay. Yeah, I'll go down there. How do I go down there?
I don't like the look of this. I can't get in here. Oh, it's full of blood in there.
OOF
Is that a light?
OHHUHU
HUHUHUHEHHU
ohuhuh
hi, OH. That's..
ahhh..
Heads, you like heads? Okay. I like that about you. That's something that makes me
*loud groaning noise* OOOHEYYYYY
YEEEEeEeEe
*singing* I'm gonna hide under my bed cuz I got nothing better to do
yeesh
Uh, I don't think this helped me in any way
I don't think it's helping AT ALL
Well I don't know where I'm supposed to be going
Something is thumpin'
AAA AEYYYYY
*loud whispers*
HEEEEEYYY
What the heckuhh?! Hey diiiiiiick dick dick dick dick dick diiick.
I don't like this. Fuck. Man. Where am I supposed to gooouuu
I didn't press any button there that was of your own volition
That sounds bad
Should I go back in here? Visit my old pal Manno-quinno?
Oh come on in no no no no I'm going in I did not do that
Ah good the mannequin's gone my favorite thing
*evil laughter*
*echoing laughter*
HHHHHHHHHH
HEY COME ON NOOO
EYYY OK I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
wha..
WHAT I JU---REUUGHGHH
*angry* OOOOOOHHH
You piece of shit
you piece of garbo!!
You piece of garbo! Oh, fuck you.
God, okay, I gotta get back in there. I guess oh hi, okay, ah
ooh ah um
Ex-ah uh
Okay, alright. Alright. Hey, hey hey hey. Hey
heyyyyyy
*whispering*
Stranger danger. Are they still down there?
Well that's open okay. All right. You know what I'm down. I'm down to clown. I'll give it a go
I'll give it the old gander with my eye peepers
Hello, ooh twins love it! Uhh great mm
my favorite thing
Ooh OJ OK We just moved in there's still a couple boxes
That should be delivered by tomorrow later that night as I was getting ready to go to sleep
I heard a creepy scream coming from outside
I looked out the window into the woods pretty sure I saw a tall figure standing there
I woke Esther up and told her what I'd seen, but when we looked again it was gone
I guess I was very tired and needed sleep immediately oh yeah, this is
PROBABLY NOT DEEEMOONNS
*woman singing opera in distance*
Elijah?? Okay, let's just follow this logic here
*singing continues, getting closer, with thunder roaring outside*
Alright, okay. I don't know why there's music coming from over there but I'm gonna assume that's not good and oh hey
You're open now GREAT let's open the whole house up
HUHAHAHUHUA
Oh, good paintings....art.. art and music greeatt
*loud groaning*
OK WHY WHY WHY AND WHERE
WHERE AND WHY AND HOW AND what do I do? I don't know what I do!
Oh, hi, okay. All right. Well you just come on meandering down. I don't know how to get away from you
You kill me. I'm gonna be very pissed
Okay, alright. Yeah
*loud whispering*
AHHHH
*loud whispering* NINININININI AH IM RUNNING I THINK I DONT KNOOOWW
I DONT KNOOOW
Okay, then.
Oh another key, okay? What is the second of two keys that I haven't--I have no idea
I don't know where they go. I don't know where they go
I don't know where these keys go
Weird.
Oh OK, found a key for this
That's good.
*DUUUUN* ohhh hi, you're tall
Oooh
I can't stay here everything reminds me of her. Everywhere I turn I feel her presence
It feels like she's still here and watching me last night. I couldn't sleep
I heard a loud knocking noise coming from one of the walls in the house. I got out of the room and saw a picture was knocked down from the wall
I think I'm going crazy. I must leaaaave..you got that right-oh my god, I gotta leaaaaave
oof, I gotta get out of heeere
*sarcastically* oh the music stopped oh great oh gooood..
Ooh that sounds great-the key okay the key? Which key to what what are we talking abou-oook
Okay
Okay, someone on the chandelier?
OH someone is on the chandelier
*singing* I'm gonna swing from the Chandelier
*wind noise*
Oh boy, that's a fun sound
These are all fun sounds HEY, OH WHY AND WHERE AND HOW, HIIIII
HEYYY
What the heck?
carry on
OH hi, hello, that is a definite yes OH
ohhhh
All right, okay, all right, okay? All right..
OK do I follow you??
im not gonna..
*distant groaning*
Oh, that's not good. That's a- that's- OH hi
O-OH. OHHHHH.
OHHHHHHHHHHH
OHHH.
O-OHH-OHH OHHH.
Ooh, an altar. Altars are always good
ooh, frick
Bride-to-be disappears Esther Deighton
Mysteriously *jumbled* a few days before her wedding her future husband was away on a business trip  after coming back his soon to be wife
Was missing- wedding dress is nowhere to be found
ehh
Okay, what does that mean? What does that mean!?
What does that mean
*door creaks* HI
OHHHHHHHHHHHH
OHHHH
HI HI HI HI HI HIDEY HIDEY HIDEY HO
heyyy..how's it going there
ahhhhhahahahaha
Not bad
awh
that was good
That was good. I mean the death was like you know whatever, and then I started all over
But that was good because it made things work different slightly but different
This is a really good start to a horror game, and I hope to see more because this was just a demo
Good stuff though lots of detail lots of ambience
Loved it. I was terrified too. Do more with the mannequin actually don't I don't want it
but do more with the mannequin so-
Thank you
Everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below if you want to see a full game
Of this also mention that in the comments as well, and thank you everybody again for watching as always
I will see you in the next video. Bye Bye!
*outro music*